[Música]
en mi amar al menos nueve muertos dejar
una nueva jornada de violenta represión
contra las manifestaciones ciudadanas
miles de personas siguen marchando para
exigir el regreso de la democracia y
seis periodistas fueron acusados de
incitar a la desobediencia civil entre
ellos una de la agencia estadounidense
apple
10 cohetes cayeron sobre una base
militar que alberga a tropas
estadounidenses por el momento se
confirma una víctima fatal este es el
segundo ataque en menos de un mes a una
base con tropas de la unión americana
derecho se produce cuando faltan dos
días para la histórica visita del papa-
francisco al país tenemos reporte
el presidente de eeuu prometió que todos
los adultos del país contarán con
vacunas contra el coi 19 para finales de
mayo también destacó el acuerdo para que
el fabricante de medicamentos berg ayuda
a producir la vacuna de johnson y
johnson
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y el mundo aquí en paz 24 mi
nombre es liliana valencia nueva jornada
de violencia y represión es mi animal
este miércoles al menos 9 personas han
muerto incluidos dos menores de edad a
causa de los disparos de las fuerzas de
seguridad para dispersar las protestas
como lo registran los medios locales
desde el golpe militar ocurrido el
pasado primero de febrero han muerto más
de 30 personas a esto se suma la
detención de seis periodistas mientras
que en el frente diplomático países de
la asean se esfuerzan por unirse para
hablar en una sola voz
extintores para nublar la vista de las
fuerzas de seguridad en rangún desde
primera hora de la mañana la policía se
apresura a dispersar a los manifestantes
utilizando gases lacrimógenos balas de
goma y también munición real
los servicios de emergencia de la ciudad
siguen sumando muertos en una nueva
jornada de represión igual que la ciudad
de mandalay y en el norte la segunda
ciudad más grande del país un balance
que cada vez pesa más al menos 30
personas han sido ya asesinadas desde el
inicio del movimiento muertes que
magnifican la ira la muerte de un
manifestante asesinado la semana pasada
no disuadió a sus amigos de protestar el
martes durante su funeral
queremos democracia justicia para
nuestros héroes que dieron la vida por
esta revolución seguiremos luchando
hasta que la justicia esté de nuestro
lado desde el golpe de estado militar
del 1 de febrero la junta militar ha
endurecido las penas por alterar el
orden público los periodistas están
pagando el precio este miércoles seis
periodistas que cubrían las protestas
fueron acusados de incitar a la
desobediencia civil en el marco
diplomático poco progreso los países de
la asean no han pedido con una sola voz
el retorno a la democracia y se
conforman con pedir al ejército
contención y diálogo
karn esto nos preocupa porque la
democracia birmana está amenazada pero
también porque la paz y la seguridad en
la región pueden verse afectadas ya que
emanan aguas
naciones unidas- celebrará el viernes
una reunión del consejo de seguridad
sobre la situación en mianmar la
institución tendrá que decidir quién
representa a mianmar en su seno
representante que estaba en el cargo
hasta ahora fue destituido por la junta
tras condenar el golpe de estado pero
informó que no va a dimitir y que la
junta no tiene derecho a retirarlo de su
cargo diez cohetes cayeron hoy sobre una
base militar en el oeste de irak que
alberga a tropas de la coalición
liderada por eeuu hasta ahora se
confirma la muerte de un contratista
civil los cohetes golpearon la base ain
al asad el ataque se produce después de
varias semanas de tensiones entre eeuu e
irán en suelo iraquí y cuando faltan
sólo dos días para la visita del papa-
francisco al país es un pontífice
aseguró que su viaje sigue en firme a
pesar de los ataques
catalina gómez ángel no está enviada
especial a irak está en la ciudad de
tikrit a unos 140 km de bagdad y nos
amplió previamente esta información
el ataque de esta mañana a la base de al
asad de la provincia de anbar no muy
lejos de siria hace parte de ese largo
enfrentamiento que hemos visto entre
esas milicias especialmente pro iraníes
y eeuu ellos piden que las tropas
norteamericanas en este país se retienen
en cambio no hace parte de esa larga
disputa entre ira en eeuu especialmente
en un momento donde la atención es al
máximo por si eeuu regresa al acuerdo
nuclear pero irán pide que se levanten
las sanciones económicas ya semanas
atrás habíamos visto otro ataque en una
base con presencia norteamericana en
ebril donde murió un contratista y hoy
tenemos este segundo ataque que también
podría ser respuesta a ese ataque que
hicieron los norteamericanos como
respuesta al derbi en la región de
adjudica mal dentro desidia donde había
muerto al menos un miliciano proiraní y
todo esto se da días antes de que llegue
al país el papá
francisco en una situación de seguridad
que él ha dicho la vuelta ha repetido
hoy que vendrá al país a mandar un
mensaje de apoyo a decir aquí es
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden replanteo su pronóstico sobre la
vacunación en el país prometió que todos
los adultos estarán vacunados a finales
de mayo dos meses antes de lo que se
calculaba la promesa llega después de
anunciar un acuerdo que en el que la
farmacéutica merck contribuirá en la
fabricación de la vacuna johnson y
johnson matías a raíz nos amplia
el objetivo finales de mayo el
presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció que
su país está en camino de tener
suficientes vacunas para todos los
adultos en apenas tres meses con uno de
mis primeros objetivos en el cargo fue
decir que se administrarían 100 millones
de vacunas en mis primeros 100 días de
mandato hemos llegado a la mitad de ese
objetivo en 37 días y confío en que
llegaremos hasta el final
para lograrlo badén informó que la
farmacéutica merck a ayudará a fabricar
la vacuna kobe 19 de una sola dosis de
su rival johnson and johnson en una
asociación que según dijo es similar a
las que se dieron durante la segunda
guerra mundial weo sound boat en defensa
pero también invocamos la ley de
producción de defensa para equipar las
instalaciones de merck con los
estándares necesarios para fabricar con
seguridad la vacuna de johnson y johnson
las instalaciones de fabricación de
vacunas de johnson y johnson empezarán a
funcionar las 24 horas del día antes
por último baile ordenó a los estados
que dieran prioridad a la vacunación de
los profesores para garantizar que los
niños puedan volver a la escuela de
forma rápida y segura señalando que
muchos padres estaban saliendo del
mercado laboral para ayudar a sus hijos
a aprender a distancia con 3 vacunas ya
disponibles la reapertura de las
escuelas es una necesidad dijo bayram
citando la creciente preocupación por la
salud mental de los niños y el riesgo de
que se amplíen las
vamos ahora a nueva york donde crece el
escándalo de acoso sexual sobre el
gobernador demócrata andrew cuomo tres
mujeres lo han denunciado lo cual pone
en cuestión su futuro político mientras
tanto los legisladores estatales
llegaron a un acuerdo para despojarlo de
sus poderes de emergencia vinculados a
la pandemia y devolver a asuntos como
los cierres al control local para hablar
este tema vamos con nuestra corresponsal
mamen salam amén buenos días y cuéntenos
la asamblea estatal le ha retirado a
como los poderes de emergencia que
supone esto exactamente
y muy buenos días pues estos son unos
poderes que como decía se fueron contra
logrados al gobernador andrew como
durante la pandemia y que se suponía que
iban a durar hasta el 30 de abril pero
la asamblea estatal ha decidido
retirarlos debido a las acusaciones de
los últimos días de acoso por parte del
gobernador con estos poderes que es lo
que podía llevar a cabo el gobernador
pues emitir órdenes ejecutivas como por
ejemplo el uso de la mascarilla que ese
tipo de órdenes ya emitidas se van a
mantener lo que no podrá hacer es emitir
nuevas órdenes salvo que sean
estrictamente necesarias para hacer
frente a la pandemia y aún así en este
caso van a tener que ser supervisadas
por los legisladores como por ejemplo la
apertura de nuevos comercios o extender
a la ocupación dentro de los
restaurantes o los bares desde el
partido demócrata cada vez son más los
compañeros que dan la espalda al
gobernador y desde el ala más
progresista del partido piden su
dimisión en caso de que estas
acusaciones de acoso así confirmen el
gobernador andrew como de momento no ha
hecho comentarios acerca de abandonar su
cargo en el que lleva ya
tres mandatos eso sí ha dicho que pondrá
todo de su parte y ayudará lo que sea
necesario para llevar a cabo una
investigación de lo ocurrido también
pero como se espera que se desarrolle la
investigación contra el gobernador como
si esta investigación va a estar en
manos de la fiscal general del estado de
nueva york que va a tener el poder para
solicitar todos los documentos que
considere necesario y eso incluye
correos electrónicos y mensajes de texto
desde la administración que como ya han
dicho que van a poner todas las
facilidades para facilitar toda la
información que sea necesaria y la
fiscal general también va a poder llamar
a todos los testigos que considere
oportunos incluido el propio gobernador
andrew como que ha dicho que prestará
juramento de manera voluntaria la fiscal
general va a estar apoyada por una serie
de abogados que van a llevar a cabo una
investigación para ver si el gobernador
andrew cómo ha ido en contra de algunos
de los derechos humanos del estado de
nueva york relacionados con la cuestión
del acoso no debemos olvidar que el
gobernador andrew como por ley debe
recibir un informe semanal sobre esta
investigación que se va a llevar a cabo
y además va a ser él mismo el que
autoricen los pagos para esta
investigación por lo que muchos
legisladores creen que no va a hacer
esta investigación realmente sea
independiente y algunos de ellos ya han
dicho que no descartan más adelante
pedir que el gobernador andrew como se
ha sometido a un juicio político a un
impeachment gracias mamen sala nuestra
corresponsal en nueva york por la
información y continuamos en mexico
porque el senado aprobó una polémica ley
de reforma la industria eléctrica el
proyecto impulsado por el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador busca
fortalecer la soberanía al darle más
poder a la empresa estatal comisión
federal de electricidad con 68 votos a
favor y 58 en contra el pleno del senado
aprobó la iniciativa que el mes pasado
también fue aprobada por la cámara de
diputados- sectores de la oposición
argumentan que la nueva ley va en
detrimento de los generadores privados
de energía principalmente de los que
producen energías renovables y ahuyenta
la inversión privada anunciaron que
acudirán a la corte suprema
a indignación en afganistán donde tres
periodistas fueron asesinadas a tiros en
la ciudad oriental de jalalabad el
estado islámico se atribuyó la
responsabilidad de los asesinatos
argumentando que las comunicadoras
trabajaban en un medio afín al gobierno
afgano
hoy se realizaron los funerales de las
tres mujeres que fueron tiroteadas en
dos ataques diferentes cuando salían de
la estación de televisión en mi casa
donde trabajaban durante las últimas
semanas periodistas activistas y jueces
han sido blanco de ataques armados o con
explosivos en el país
para conmemorar el día internacional de
la mujer este 8 de marzo france24 les
trae desde esta semana una serie de
informes donde le descontaremos el papel
de las mujeres y los retos particulares
que han tenido que enfrentar durante la
pandemia comenzamos en argentina allí
las mujeres han sufrido especialmente
como muchos países una sobrecarga las
tareas de cuidado los hijos la casa la
alimentación combinadas con un mayor
nivel de precarización laboral que el de
los hombres según el ministerio de
economía el 75 por ciento esas tareas en
el hogar las hacen en las mujeres
nuestro corresponsal en buenos aires-
natalio cos hoy nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe por el impacto social
y psicológico que eso ha traído sobre
las mujeres argentinas
marcela lorenzo vive en este pequeño
apartamento con dos de sus hijos y su
pareja
aquí la encontró la pandemia intentando
combinar las tareas del hogar su
actividad en la comunidad afroargentina
y sus estudios para docentes de primaria
los más duros fueron los primeros meses
del encierro ay fueron caóticos caóticos
porque según momento te digo julio
vacaciones de julio que en realidad no
fueron vacaciones pero así es como
colapsada la situación de marcela se
repitió en millones de hogares en todo
el país con una sobrecarga de tareas
domésticas tal como determinó un estudio
que llevó adelante la investigadora
karina vida seca expresó en forma
significativa en que el 92 por ciento
más exactamente un 92,6 se encargaron de
acompañar las actividades escolares de
los hijos ingés la sobrecarga termina
teniendo un efecto emocional
la psicóloga sandra berna voz ha estado
siguiendo a muchas mujeres a lo largo de
la pandemia lo que se siente es
el estrés por un lado el hartazgo el
agotamiento en muchos momentos la
sensación de desesperanza
yo veo estragos importantes ya los veo
este veo niveles de irritabilidad muy
grandes veo vínculos que se han
deteriorado un montón en su casa marcelo
lorenzo pasó por algunas de esas
emociones creo que en un momento colapse
colapse con la casa con la pc con la
familia con la obsecuencia estudios
novia es esa interacción ese encuentro
con el otro con la otra con el otro lo
necesito muchísimo este es como de
encontrarme levantarme y que hago pero
el desafío ahora a medida que se abre
más y más actividades es desarmar la
rutina del encierro por lo pronto ella
está dando más espacio a sus estudios su
activismo social y saliendo algunos días
por semana a trabajar acercándose de a
poco a algo parecido a la normalidad
así finalizamos por esta emisión porque
ustedes pueden continuar con más de la
programación que tenemos para ustedes y
también visita nuestra página web las 24
punto com nos vemos más adelante con más
información quédense con nosotros
[Música]